former executive uh in the nfl and long
time grocery shopper in philadelphia and
also uh spent some time at the cleveland
browns organization on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line joe banner back here on
the richardson show how you been joe
i got to hear you do the play-by-play at
the pouring of a beer that's just that
was that was priceless thank you sir you
know what i just try to paint word
pictures for the radio audience and
jason kelsey's a hell of a picture that
was great
that's an emmy right there
thank you very much joe uh okay jump
let's jump into it right here uh when
when do you think we see the contract of
aaron rodgers um
uh cause andrew brant uh a colleague of
ours for many years in the front office
of green bay thinks that um
his sense of things is when it all comes
out we'll see that rogers is only making
a year to your commitment to green bay
and vice versa what do you think
well i i i don't think that will be the
case it would be my guess but i don't
think it's going to be
this what we've been reading about
um i think we're going to see something
in which
there'll be at least a couple years
with the guarantees that are going to be
in there and the front loading of the
deal
uh
hopefully we don't have to spend every
minute of the off season talking about
this but i don't think it's going to be
you know people talking like a four-year
extension which is like six years out
they may do that to look good and create
a number that excites rogers and his
agent and
make big headlines
um so i'm probably in between what we're
seeing reported on what andrew's saying
um i i actually think at this point he's
going to finish his career in green bay
it doesn't make sense to me this was
kind of the moment to move if he was
going to
i had been thinking that he was going to
stay they just thought there were too
many signs
but wait
i like android he's a friend but i hope
he's wrong just for the
sake of those of us that get tired of
hearing about it
so uh what would that mean so two-year
commitment that would kind of make sense
too that green bay is saying we'll give
you all this money we want an extra year
out of you but then there's the fact of
jordan love sitting there as well do you
think that
this significant um
signing regardless of how long it is
indicates that the team is
kind of
realizing that the drafting of love will
not result in him being the starting
quarterback of the greenway parkers what
do you think yeah i'm not going to go
that far although i certainly it's
certainly the possible outcome and i
think it's clear that
if they were just seeing phenomenal
things from jordan love in we wouldn't
be having this conversation with having
a different one
but i think what they're doing which i
think is smart is it's almost impossible
to find the aaron rodgers and you have
to be really stupid to not keep in there
as long as he can possibly function at a
level that gives you a chance to win
championship and i don't think anybody
could have watched in the last couple of
years and think he's not at that level
now now when will that end i think
they'll write a contract that you know
they'll be in a position frankly to kind
of mutually agree on that as i said and
i could easily end up being wrong about
this at this point i think he's going to
complete his career in green bay which
is an old-fashioned guy and a little bit
getting up there in age i'm glad to see
it's not as often as it used to be and i
think it's great when it happens
especially the
player of this caliber
but i think that they'll have a year
they'll have enough guaranteed money in
the deal and front loaded enough that
moving off of him after a year or even
two will be really challenging to their
future cap i don't think they care
anymore
um so i think it's going to be
determined by how well he's playing and
how anxious he is to keep playing i
think he is now completely in control of
the situation
and people didn't realize he really
didn't have an out this year he had kind
of an understanding that if they
couldn't work out he could get out but
it wasn't the brady situation where
brady was completely in control and he
could leave whenever you know he wanted
to
uh the rogers thing is much more of a
commitment to green bay than even the
last brady contract was in new england
when you say that you don't think they
care anymore
uh put putting a few more meat on the
bones about
the packers and their the way that they
normally do business or have done
business and the way that they're
currently doing business right now what
it means
for green bay joe yeah i think it means
that for the next two to three years
they're going to be the uh
favorite or in the top two or three
teams in the nfc to make the soup on i
think they're going to keep rogers
as long as they feel like and he wants
to play that he gives them a chance to
win that super bowl i mean i think for
the first time frankly in a couple of
years they have some continuity
and kind of the opposite of of what
andrew is suggesting i think they can
plan ahead for at least a couple years
on how to manage their cap and how to
maximize
uh taking advantage of it listen when i
ran the eagles we were we were
frequently resigning players earlier in
most teams and trying to sign them at a
younger age
and people always ask me well you just
think this is a strategy that worked for
anybody i used to say no if you have an
older quarterback that gives you a
chance to win a super bowl you should be
doing the opposite of what i'm doing
and i think that's what we could see
green bay do which is basically you know
meaning that you're going to minimize
the short term
challenges for all your expensive
players
so you can maximize the number of good
players you can fit in your roster and
you're going to pay for that three or
four years from now and in the meantime
you're hoping you at least stole one
super bowl and had a couple of other
really good years i think that's we're
going to see them do joe banner long
time nfl executive here on the rich
eisen show what did you make of the
wilson trade the compensation the
acquisition of of wilson and denver uh
uh you know obviously there's a sale of
a team going on right now and that that
uh that certainly helps the broncos uh
try and extract extract uh you know more
millions if not uh a billion out of
somebody what do you make of the
entirety of this big deal joe that's
great one of the point where
words that begin with m don't mean
anything it's only b's or billionaires
the price doesn't go up a few million it
goes up a few billion right anyway uh
you know listen i applaud denver and at
the same time i'm not really sure it
moves them up that much in their
division i mean i like bold moves
i think they do have a good team i
usually reject the notion that they're a
quota back away from being good but i
actually think that is the case
in denver it was bold there's no doubt
it was aggressive i love when a general
manager is more interested and willing
to take a risk to make the team good and
at the same time knows that he's putting
his own reputation on the line and he's
willing to do that we don't see enough
people do that so i i applaud it
i never think it's a good idea to wait
right away a great quarterback and i
think great russell wilson is a great
quarterback i think he's going to get a
chance to show it now i think he is
right that he's been held back by a
terrible offensive line in a very
conservative scheme
but the truth is denver's in a division
with at least two teams maybe even three
that it's going to be very very hard to
get ahead of in the standings and make
the playoffs and win the division
but their choice was to sit there and
just kind of accept that or do something
really bold and aggressive and try to
change that i applaud that they did that
and uh i'm a huge russell wilson fan i
think it's a good roster and i think
they're gonna
just add to the dominance of the afc and
i don't think we've ever seen have you
ever seen this kind of imbalance of
quarterback play between the two
conferences and for the next decade it's
going to be true no i know and you you
could take a look at uh the nfc with
rogers and obviously there's
matthew stafford and we'll see how many
more super bowls if he's lucky enough to
to get back uh dak
in the um
in the nfc and uh you know carson wentz
is now back in the nfc and i want to
kind of put a pin in that with you joe
banner while also wondering what you
think seattle's plan is here why they
why this happened and what you think
uh john schneider and pete carroll's
next move may be based on your knowledge
of the situation in any way
well i
i'm torn because on one hand you know
pete could easily play a game
play the game in a way that
doesn't need a dominant quarterback i
don't think it wins your championships
that is his personality i mean could he
be thinking he's going to go ahead with
drew lock and try to draft somebody else
and develop him and look at it again in
a couple of years could he be sitting
there with all these assets and looking
at something like desean watson i don't
know that there's any other people you
can acquire in the short term is he
really just saying you know we're going
to be just okay for the next couple
years and then we're going to you know
turn it around by then head coach 70
years old i can't really picture that so
i just think it's a
kind of a capitulation from seattle
and acceptance that the uh
i'm not sure they're accepting this but
my prediction would be that they're not
going to be competitive even in their
own division here for the immediate
future i mean what they had in russell
is the thing everybody wants and it's
the hardest thing to find
and they traded away and they got a
great package
of assets i think they got fair
compensation but
when it comes to quarterback it's a
little bit like basketball where you
have a small number of players can have
a huge impact on the game quarterback's
the same thing in the nfl
if you don't have it you're in trouble
and i know they don't have it and i
don't see the path to getting it
so
i understand why they did it if the
relationships are broken down but i
think they're going to end up regretting
it joe banner here on the rich eisen
show uh you just mentioned moments ago
the arms race in the afc is off the
charts i mean off
the charts in the afc west alone and
then you've got burrow
in the afc
north with lamar and trevor lawrence who
knows how much of a leap he can make and
young quarterbacks that have been
drafted in the afc east um to go along
with josh allen for crying out loud um
so the colts now have an opening and i'm
wondering what you think their
their positioning is is it similar to
what you just said about seattle in
terms of capitulating to a bad
relationship and it's going to be a
problem what do you think
well i think the difference is i know
he's taking a lot of heat for what he
did once mistake but i think chris
ballot is if not the best and the best
couple of general managers in the league
and he knows he's got to fix this i
think they'll make some a move that will
be reasonably aggressive short-term and
then try to find a long-term solution so
i actually think the speculation about
somebody like jimmy garoppolo ending up
in indianapolis
has a real chance and i think there'll
be a few bidders on that i think it's a
probably the type of person you could
see a pittsburgh type of team target as
well so
i think san francisco is going to
benefit by being kind of patient here
and letting this play out a little bit
and then kind of ending up with maybe
two or three teams that really badly
need a quarterback are in a position to
win short term and he may be the last
guy standing that gives any team a
serious chance
of winning in the immediate future with
the talent they have and i think that's
the colts i think the cults are a much
much better team than we realize right
now they just need to get that
quarterback spot at a high level so um
let's talk a little bit about whence now
i'll unpin it um now that we're we're on
the subject matter and you know your
former team in philadelphia and you know
how he roseman very well an aggressive
move made for him and we know his whole
story about having an mvp season before
his you know his his reckless play you
could say i mean he was a reckless
abandon however you want to put it um
that we've seen over and over again from
him knocked him out foles wins the
championship he winds up in indianapolis
eventually he's now one and done and now
he's a twice-traded quarterback what
what is your assessment of wence
now that you've seen him as a pro
for all these years and what gives
is essentially the question
you know just first to clear and
transparent i was a big fan of that pick
i was a big fan of his play i was a big
fan of them giving it a long
very at the time expensive contract so
take what i say next with a grain of
salt since i'm old for three of my
predictions of what went so far but
i just think at this point you know
there's enough evidence on the tip you
got two of the smartest for offices in
football
that were deeply invested in this guy
and had to pay a huge price to not have
him on their team anymore
and then you can watch what you can see
with your own eyeballs every sunday
i just don't see how you turn around and
make a bet on that guy to lead your team
and be able to beat some of the
quarterbacks we just talked about some
of the quality of the teams that we're
seeing out there just again in their own
division i don't even see how they get
to winning the division you know this
kind of move
and this is always one of my pet things
since i
felt like negotiating with one of my
strengths i just
who did they think they were bidding
against that they had to pay that in
compensation and take on the entire
contract so i've actually been very
critical of the trade wence will make
some spectacular plays he'll have some
games in which like oh my god we did
find the guy
but when the 17 games are done
you're going to be disappointed in his
play that that's what i believe at this
point but as i say
i'm all for free and my analysis of when
so
take it how you want well what's the
scuttlebutt or word or what have you on
his his locker room presence and things
of that nature and off the field there's
just always some sort of hum in the
background right some sort of noise
about that
and i'm wondering what you may
you know wouldn't washington know
something
before making that trade right you'd
like to think so and and you said it
right i mean he he does manage to have a
few players in each of the places that
he's been
that gravitate towards him uh become
very close to him uh
you know very committed to him i mean
you know we see it we saw darius leonard
speak out the other day this is not some
unimportant
uh player that doesn't know the
difference between good guys and bad
guys or good players and bad players and
in each place we've had a few of those
but that's the minority
um
it's hard to identify why i mean he's no
doubt strong-willed he's no doubt hard
to coach
um everybody that's worked with has made
it clear that he has sometimes too much
confidence
but we're going to see the same thing
that's going to happen in in washington
he's going to have a group of guys that
are going to be very enthralled and
taken with him and want to play with him
and
you know help him take them somewhere
but he's also going to have a larger
group
then it's just not going to feel right
about him as the leader of their team of
the organization
and
you know you talk to different people
you get kind of different explanations
or theories nothing seems that clear as
to you know what is about him that
causes people to react that way
but if they think they're bringing
somebody in is going to kind of
continue the improvement of the culture
that i think ronavara has started in
washington i don't think this is the
right guy to do that job is too
controversial joe banner long-time nfl
executive here on the rich housing show
few more minutes left with him what do
you think howie roseman in the eagles
plan is we're hearing fletcher cox is on
the block we also heard that prior to
the news involving calvin ridley
suspension the eagles were aggressive in
trying to go get
him um and then there's those the matter
of the three first-round draft choices
and jalen hurts
uh as the starting quarterback what do
you think the gambit is afoot in
philadelphia right now joe so i think
the eagle's view is that the
[Music]
they don't have to panic about
quarterback even though i think they
have doubts that hertz is the answer
um and that if they don't find something
better and they give him another chance
to kind of prove he may be better than
what they think which i think is is
solid but not like the guys gonna carry
a championships
um i don't think they care if they have
to wait a year to do that
so what i my prediction in the simplest
sense is they're going to trade one of
those first-round picks so they help
hopefully have
two first-round picks next year heavy
ammunition in case they don't get the
guy this year
i've said that i think they're the most
likely team to be aggressive about
desean watson
um i really put them in carolina as the
two kind of favorites finalists and i
lean toward the eagles little just
because they have a history of making
those kind of bold aggressive moves that
could blow up in your face
um you know we did it when i was there
with michael vick so they have the
personality to take on that kind of risk
but i think their attitude is that they
can't get them at the right price
they're going to position themselves to
be in next year's draft and have the
ammunition to move off if necessary
and know that whether it's hertz
develops or next year's draft that's the
latest at which they'll have a
quarterback they think and hope can
carry them for the next decade
so i think we're going to see them you
know maybe take a shot at like a watson
if he can get his issues cleared up not
completely but mostly certainly the
criminal part of it
um if that doesn't happen i think we're
going to see them put this on hold for a
year other than i think they'll trade
one of those first-round picks to have
more ammunition next year to be in a
position to get the guy before i let you
go joe uh the news that khalil mack is
coming here to los angeles for the
chargers um it's a two and a six um for
for for mac
and so what does that deal tell you
about the way both teams are approaching
matters in their respective
neighborhoods bears and charges what
does that indicate to you
yeah i mean everything and i think it's
good i mean i think that the bears
realize we have a ways to go and let's
not fool ourselves into spending an
extra 25 30 million dollars this year
uh thinking that you know so we win
seven games instead of five i mean
that's that's a stuck in the middle
gonna get you nowhere over time
so they're taking a step backwards that
i think they need to take to have a
chance to become really good and
hopefully they'll use these
these assets effectively so i think it's
smart on their part i don't think it
pretends that they don't think khalil
can play well anymore i just think it's
where they are in their evolution and i
say about general managers the thing
that distinguishes the good ones from
the just okay ones
are the ability to not just know how to
pick players but how to build a team
so i think that if you understand the
fact that where they are right now the
right thing to do is kind of tear it
down a little bit more and then rebuild
it with a better foundation
if i was a bears fan i'd be really
encouraged by that
on the other hand the chargers are in
that position we talk so much about you
know rookie contract quarterback
and a chance to take advantage of that
opportunity and have a chance to see if
they can come out of the next couple
years before he becomes expensive with a
soup wall
and i think we're just seeing the
beginning of what they're going to do to
try to make that happen and that's
exactly what they should be doing so
you know i focus a lot on team building
and how smart is the approach i actually
think this trait says both teams
should feel good about the people they
have in leadership right now they're
reflecting very well where they are in
their evolution they're evaluating our
team correctly and they're making the
right moves for this moment in time and
i certainly think it's the case for the
chargers to be it's wise to do that and
put some more eggs in this year's basket
certainly if um herbert proves he
deserves a josh allen type deal in the
uh and the time
frame that alan received it and one in
which kyler murray appears to be with
his agent pushing for
that if you are showing and proving to
have a special talent being drafted so
high
atop the draft you're not going to wait
to be done with year four to get your
long-term deal or going into year four
you want you you want it right after
yeah you want it right after year three
not going into year four you want it
right now
um
fans should know if they don't i mean
you can't sign the quarterback before
three years
so we've seen both successes and
failures but the top quarterbacks for
the most part are getting these new
deals after three years and so you
better be prepared to do it which really
means
they have one more year before he
becomes at least significantly more
expensive and probably two more before
he becomes extremely expensive and
they're doing the right thing they're
trying to take advantage of that moment
and get a chance to hold the trophy i
guess back in your day there was no
instagram accounts to scrub pictures of
to show that uh your star player is
upset with you
how do you think last one for you the
kyler murray situation is going to
resolve itself in arizona do you think
well i think he's making a mistake
in going so nuclear so public so quickly
i do think he's right to put the team in
a position where he's not risking his
health in his future without getting the
kind of contract and guarantee that he
you know deserves now we can argue
exactly what that number is but clearly
he deserves a quality new contract as a
starter but i just don't understand the
strategy of putting a team on a
defensive publicly this early i mean the
league year hasn't started
and 10 days ago he's issuing you know
press releases
it's just
you know i mean we're all human and
we're you know it's easy to get somebody
feeling a little bit attacked and backed
into the corner and that's not where you
want to be in the early stages of any
negotiation especially for a quarterback
who you not only want to sign but you
want him to feel good about it when
you're done he's facing a team he's the
person that's going to really determine
how well you do over the next three four
five years
so why are you coming out just so
aggressively i mean okay i suspect they
had some conversation with the team that
didn't go the way they wanted to but
you know save it you know
maybe you do that in june maybe you do
it in july maybe you do it a year from
now but
in february i don't understand the
strategy i just don't think it's setting
up the right tone to get a deal done but
i don't think that cardinals have a
choice they're not going to go back to
looking for a quarterback they're going
to get a deal done the question is this
year next year clearly the agent is
trying to force it to be this year he
can only do that if the team cooperates
so why get them so upset before we even
come out of the starting box joe love
your um takes as always thanks for the
call look for my text again certainly
after the new league year opens up and
some dust settles i'd love to have you
back my pleasure always willing and
enjoy it thank you right back at you
that's joe banner
i follow him on twitter you should as
well
great
insight i love the way he just
puts it out there that's why he was such
a great executive there in philadelphia
just puts it right out there hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here